it's becoming increasingly common to
start using machine learning or AI
driven techniques to make decisions the
world over so for example you know
credit checks health checks and these
can be life-changing
right so it's really important we get
this right you could find yourself
turned down through a mortgage on your
dream house because quite literally the
computer says no let's talk a little bit
about classification so now we have a
data set where we've got labels all
right so we've got some input features
or input attributes or dimensions lots
of instances and we've got some labels
for these attributes all right and so
we've got for example books and the type
of book or music and the genre with the
music things that we want to start to
try and classify so supervised learning
is the idea that we've got labels for
our data so we're still gonna have
instances we're gonna have attributes or
dimensions to our instances but we've
also now got labels for our data and so
classification is the process of
learning how to correctly assign these
labels to these instances before we
start talking about classifiers let's
talk a little bit about the learning
process and machine learning process we
want to use it's not enough to say I've
got my data set and I can correctly
predict all of the classes right because
then someone will ask well what happens
if we have any new data that we haven't
seen before right maybe you've got some
medical data and you can correct me
diagnose all of the diseases but a new
patient comes along and you could
incorrectly diagnose the disease right
that's not helped anyone what we need is
a regimented way of training and testing
these approaches so that we know how
well they apply in the real world so
what we're going to do is we've got some
data set just like before where we've
got some instances and we've got some
attributes this way and so you know we
might have a lot of attributes a few it
doesn't really matter and we also now
have our labels which we often call Y
right but this is going to be a vector
of all of the labels for data so this
could be label one-one B's could be a
few twos down here and this could be a
few three so this is a bit like our
tennis example where we had this is the
weather outlook and are we going to play
tennis today right yes or no so that you
could have multiple labels or just two
for binary classification it's not
enough just to train a classifier over
all this data we want to make sure that
this classifier will work properly when
we apply a new data to it so what we're
going to do is we're going to separate
this data into training sets
and testing sets so we're going to train
on the training set then we're going to
test as we go on the validation set and
then right at the end when we're
finished we're going to do a final test
on our test set the reason we do this is
it's a very safe way to make sure that
we don't accidentally gain the system we
don't accidentally report incredibly
good results on the training set but
that's because we all just show the
Machine those things so we hold out the
validation of a test set for later to
make sure that it will generalize now
exactly how much of your data goes in
the training validation and testing set
is really up to you
right typically you might use something
like 70% for training 15% for validation
of 15% for testing that will be quite a
reasonable way of doing it so what are
some good classifiers we could use given
that we've done this right let's imagine
we've got our instances we've got our
attributes and we split them up probably
randomly into training validation and
testing what we want to do is train our
classifier on the training set and then
test it on the validation and testing
sets to see how we're getting on so what
algorithms could we use let's start with
a simplest one of all zero are in zero
are we just take the most common label
and that's what we predict every time
it's V you've got five minutes until the
deadline just hand something in approach
to machine learning in the case of
playing tennis or not playing tennis we
could say well I play tennis more than I
didn't so we'll just assume that I'm
going to play tennis and predict yes all
the time
all right regardless of what the weather
is this is not a good way to perform
machine learning but I suppose it does
give you a baseline accuracy right if
you're baseline of just yet saying yes
to everything is sixty percent accuracy
then if your machine learning doesn't
perform at least a 60 percent we know
we've got a real problem we can go one
better than that we can use one R one R
is where we pick one of our attributes
we made classification based only on
that and then we pick the best of those
attributes
I mean it's slightly better than 0 R but
not a lot so you'll find you will find
references to bees in military too a
little bit but not very much because we
use much more powerful approaches to
this so let's talk about one example
classifier is very popular and that's
KNN or k nearest neighbor let's imagine
we've got a to attribute data set so I
like to draw in two dimensions it's just
a little easier for me and so we've got
attribute one and attribute two and
we've got some different data points in
here now
don't forget also that each of these is
going to have a prediction as well so if
this one
is going to have let's say a label if we
did play tennis when we want to test a
new data point an unseen data so a new
person comes along who may or may not
play tennis they're going to appear over
here we measure them and we find the K
number of nearest neighbors to this
point so that's this one this one this
one this one and this one so this will
be 1 2 3 4 5 6 this would be K of 6 and
then we take the majority vote or the
average of these responses so if four
out of six of these people play tennis
this would be assigned to play tennis so
the output is what in the existing data
set have we already seen nearby and can
we use that to make a prediction so this
is quite a good approach obviously
choosing K is a little bit difficult to
do right and this starts to get very
very slow when you've got hundreds and
hundreds of dimensions finding for K
nearest points to a point when you've
got tens of thousands of dimensions or
tens of thousands of instances it's not
easy to do even with good data
structures why it starts to get slow
quite quickly nevertheless this is an
effective and popular approach are there
any alternatives there is one decision
trees all right now I like decision
trees they have a nice benefit that once
we created a decision tree which is just
a series of decisions on is the data
this yes is it this no once we've done
all that we can actually look at the
rules and say ok that's how a decision
was made and that's quite a good rule
set so kind of a way of lighting a sort
of if-else programming language but
you're doing it automatically let's draw
out another data set so we've got our
instances down here and we've got our
attributes here and remember for each of
our instances we're going to have some
label that we're trying to output all
right so here well you know 1 2 3 4 5 6
and so on so let's imagine but this is a
credit score by a credit check so you've
got actually boots based on how much
money you've got how much you spent me
to me if you already have other loans
and what we want to do is make a
decision as to whether you should be
allowed more credit or not right so the
answer is yes or no
quite simply so a decision tree is going
to partition the data up based on the
attributes so let's say the first rule
is credit rating credit rating you know
greater than or equal to 5 question mark
and if the answer is yes we continue if
the answer is no then we actually output
a leaf node here
which says credit denied here we say
okay so the credit ratings are by five
it's not a no yet now we say okay do
they earn more than let's say 10,000 a
year or something like that and if the
answer is yes we proceed to the next
stage if it's no then they don't earn
enough credit denied this is what a
decision tree does now you don't have to
design this yourself there are
algorithms to produce decision trees for
you the way they will work is they will
pick one of these attributes at each
level that best separates for data out
so for example you've got a lot of
different instances of yes and no
decisions in your training set is credit
rating the best way of separating out
the yeses and anodes and one of them is
going to be best for each individual
step and we can use all of them in a
tree structure like this until we get to
a series of leaf nodes which end up with
only yeses and only nose and then is
very simple to apply this when you data
comes along we apply these rules and we
get to a decision a decision tree is
going to be equivalent to programming a
bunch of carefully chosen if statements
but of course the benefit is that you
can do this over a huge number of
attributes very very quickly without
having to do all this yourself right so
yes it's not much better than doing it
yourself but it's much quicker so let's
have a look at this in some code we're
going to change and use a different
piece of software today because for
things like classification and
prediction we're going to use Weka it's
a very simple tool that makes applying
things like decision trees very very
simple and it has some of the same data
cleaning processes as our does but in a
graphical form we've already prepared
our credit report right so we've got
credit data where we have a number of
inputs things like how much money do
they make whether they've defaulted on
any credit before we have these in a
file so I'm gonna go in here I'm gonna
find my file it's gonna be in here right
now you can load up various file types
JSON files for example we're gonna load
a CSV
it's our credit data so we have about
600 rows of whether or not people I
think it was Japan this data originally
came from were given credit or not so we
have things like age debt marital status
whether they're a customer at the bank
already whether they've got a driving
license what their current credit score
is and you can see that what Weka has
done is load all these work out whether
they're nominal or
values numerical values already so for
example credit score is a numerical
value and you can see here a quick
histogram that shows the different types
and whether they've been approved for
credit approved at the bottom Weka has
interpreted as the output or the
classification that we're trying to
achieve alright so in this data set we
have 307 you can almost see that font
307 approved and 383 denied credit so
let's train up a decision tree and see
how it does so we only go to classify
we're going to select a decision tree so
we're going to choose we could choose 0r
that's not so gonna go down to trees and
j48 which is your standard decision tree
we're gonna use a percentage split and
we're going to select 70% for our
training set this one doesn't have a
validation set we're gonna be predicting
whether one what they were approved and
then we're gonna train up like this what
happens this weapon will train the
decision tree and then it will produce
for us some measurements of its accuracy
you can see it's correctly classified
85% of the testing set which is good I
mean it means a lot to these people so
maybe those 15% could be a bit aggrieved
and then we get a confusion matrix down
here so we're saying that of the yeses a
76 were correctly
allowed credit and 22 were denied
incorrectly and if the noes a hundred
were correctly denied and nine were
accidentally allowed right so that's the
ever we can see here now the nice thing
about decision trees is we can now look
at these rules and see what they are so
we can go into visualized tree and so
you can see that the most important
attribute that is decided on is whether
or not they defaulted on a loan prior to
this so anyone that defaulting on a loan
before is immediately denied credit if
they haven't default on a loan then it
starts to look at whether they were
employed and if they are it's going to
give them credit all right it's a simple
rule system and it's the best it can do
given the amount of data we've got if
they aren't employed but it's going to
look at their income maybe they're
self-employed gonna make a decision then
whether they're married where they live
and their income again right so you can
use attributes multiple times to make
complex decision making processes so
this is a very simple tree which
actually has performed pretty well on
this data set and it's not a huge data
set for 85% that's not too bad once
you've used a classifier so KNN or a
decision tree to classify your data
you want to know really as how well as
it performs on your testing set so you
could quite simply calculate accuracy so
what is the percentage of the time that
we were correct
iein obviously that's going to be hard
to do for many classes but for credit
yes or no 85 percent is not bad right if
our if our average was guessing at 50%
it's quite a lot better than that
there's another type of classified as
perhaps a little bit more common these
days and a little bit more powerful with
decision trees and that's the support
vector machine so what is a support
vector machine well what we're going to
try and do is separate our classes based
on a line or plane or some separation in
the attributes that we have but what
we're going to do is try and maximize a
separation between these two classes to
make our decision more effective so
let's imagine we have two attributes
just like before so this is actually
because one misses attribute two don't
forget this is labeled training data so
we know which classes either been
already this is not like clustering so
maybe we have some data over here and we
have maybe some data over here now
obviously this is our quite an easy one
we're going to try to find a decision
boundary between these two classes that
maximizes a separation so for example
one decision boundary we could pick will
be this one here right but it's not
perfect because it's very close to this
point here and it's very close to this
point here so these are on the fringes
are being misclassified right and you've
got to think that this is just a
training set if we start to bring in
testing data that may appear around here
or around here maybe that's the stuff
that gets misclassified so what a
support vector machine will do is pick a
line between these data points where the
distance to the nearest point is
maximized
these nearest points are called support
vectors right so this margin here is
going to be as big as we can get it so
you can imagine if we move this around
the margins going to get bigger and
smaller now the nice thing about support
vector machines in a kind of almost
reverse PCA approach you can convert
this into a higher dimensional space and
perform quite complicated separation of
things aren't really obviously separable
like this things that are essentially we
have to have a nonlinear decision made
right so not a simple line something
more complex like a curve a lot of the
time we're going to look at precision
and recall so recall is a measure off
for all the positive things but all the
people that should have been granted
credit how
when even actually were like so we
should have said yes how many times did
we actually say yes right and that's a
measure of how good is our algorithm at
spotting that class and precision is of
the ones it spotted what percentage of
them were correct you can imagine a
situation where your recall might be
very high because you've just said yes
to everyone right so yes you spotted
every single person that should have got
credit but also your precision is low
because you were giving it to loads of
people who shouldn't have had it right
so a really good algorithm is going to
be one that has a very high precision
and a very high recall right and we
combine these measures into one score f1
or F score and this is going to be a
value between Norton one where one is
absolutely perfect and zero is doesn't
work at all where did our training data
come from in this case we've got our
train date off Internet right but if
you're a credit agency then what you're
going to do is you're going to use
humans to make these initial decisions
then you're going to train a machine and
you're going to test to see whether it
can do as well as people can do right
maybe there's nuance there that this
decision tree couldn't capture those 15
percent of people that were
misclassified is there something we
could have done better to help those
people
so what you'll find it happens in
practically is your trainer system but
maybe you don't rely on it entirely
maybe for the very obvious yes is we can
use a decision tree or some other
classifier to just say yeah those people
are fine maybe for the obvious knows we
can say no they're not going to get
credit but for the edge cases the people
in the middle maybe that's when we bring
a human into the loop so in our data set
for our training examples we're going to
have all of the attributes and then
we're crucially gonna have an already
known label for that data but says yes
that person was denied credit or they
were allow credit right so we're going
to use those training examples of input
attributes and output yes or no
decisions to train our classifier and
then we're going to test the results and
whether or not it'll work when we use
our unseen test data for unknown cases
classifiers let us put groups into
discreet labels yes or no a B or C
depending on what our situation is
they're very powerful and as long as
you've got enough training data we
should be able to use them to make
real-life decisions what we want to do
going forward is start to move from just
yes or no to can we actually produce
output values you know can we regress
actual values out of the
these algorithms let's talk a little bit
about something more powerful that's
artificial neural networks now anytime
in the media at the moment when you see
the term AI what they're actually
talking about is machine learning and
what they're talking about is some large
neural network now let's keep it a
little bit smaller for this but let's
imagine what